how you feeling my man good good i'm
excited this is cool my first my first
movie premiere listen okay hold on your
first movie premiere with brad pitt you
shut down the west side of l.a come on
bro
amazing i'm very grateful
and happy
you said this kind of felt like a
fantasy
how so it is it is i never imagined
before
being here being a red carpet of a
hollywood movie
with
so i'm very excited i'm enjoying this
moment you got to do some action in this
movie too i mean does it fulfill those
like childhood fantasies of being an
action star
now people know that that i like the
fight i like the yeah
so this is my thing you know the action
so you've got f9 oh yeah like a couple
seconds right
well yeah okay but it's still there
those are two big movies to these are
two big movies to have so how's it been
stepping into acting now do you have the
bug and you say i want to do this a
little bit more
um i want to have the the time you know
to
to
learn
to
paragraph to grow up you know in this
business because i like to act uh so yes
maybe i'm gonna spend a
couple time this
you've been at the top of the charts for
the last seven weeks you're always
breaking records with your music
[Music]
how does it feel to have such amazing
love and support from your friends when
you walked in like everybody over here
started losing their mind
no so
development
is incredible the the love of the fan
the support that they give me
all the
latino community and also the the united
states people just say hold on
right here
come on now no no i'm very grateful that
the world uh
can connect with my music even when i'm
in singing in my language spanish a lot
of people don't
don't speak spanish but love my music so
i'm very grateful for that music is a
universal language
[Music]